McDOUGALL AND JUSTIN ST-PIERRE.
DRYSDALE WALKS IT DOWN LOW
ZEGRAS INTO THE SLOT.AND THE AN
GAME's OPENI
CHANGES DIRECTION AND THE
ANOTHE
SENDS IT ACROSS.
SHOT THROUGH THE SHORT SIDE GOT
ON THE REDIRECT, AND THE JETS
HAVE T THE
ICE FOR THE ANAHEIM DUCKS.
STOPPED AT CENTRE ICE.
AND TONINATO WAS ON
EHLERS.
HE'LL PLAY IT IF THROUGH FOR
NOT ONLY GIVE THE JETS THE LEAD
BUT GET HIS FIRST
RATTLE HIM MENTALLY.
THIS IS A REALLY GOO
PIONK CHASE TOSS THE FARW COPP .
RECOGNIZES THAT HE'S GOT GUYS
THAT ARE ON IT THEIR TOESE NET.
OFF A SKATE.
AND SILFVERBERG ON THE LOOSE
PUCK.
>> Kevin: :
INTO THE JETS' ZONE.
COPP.
HE'LL DROP IGEROUS SHOT TO A GO
PLAYER.
GOOD HUSTLE BY ZEGRAS TO HOLD IT
IN.
AND CONNOR WILL BRING IT BACK
FOWLER ON FOR SILFVERBERG.
THEY WILL WASH THE ICEE GLOVE O
OVER-THINK IT BUT TALKED ABOUT
.
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS BACK UP TOP
FOR NATE SCHMIDT.
CROSS-ICE.
SCORES!
[Horn sounds] BUT COMES
IN.
HE's INSIDE THE DOT AND THAT'S .
ANDREW COPP, TRACKS
THEY WILL TRY IT AGAIN.
MORRISSEY FOR NATE
AND THE WRAPAROUND TRY, ANDND I.
>> Kevin: GOOD DEFENSIVE PLAY
FROM KYLE CONNOR, AS HE BREAKS
SIDE OFF RICKARD RAKELL.AD.
INTERCEPTED.
HES HE GETS
TRIPPED